DANNY BERNSTEIN:
Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the panel that-- it's
really obvious from the
title what this is about.
Just kidding.
So my name is Danny Bernstein,
and I lead the partnerships
team for Google+.
So we're really happy to
have everybody here.
This panel is going to introduce
some of the earliest
partners of the Google+
Sign-In product.
And I'm taking an opportunity
here with our esteemed
panelists, who we'll introduce a
second, to chat a little bit
about why they decided
to be early
adopters of this product.
Google has many, many launches
over the course of the year
and talks to lots of different
companies at different times.
And so it'll be interesting and
kind of a nice opportunity
for these guys to talk about
why they decided to adopt
early, and also, just generally
speaking, then going
into a little bit of depth on
what they're doing, actually,
with their integration.
And these are three apps
that are household
names at this point.
They have significant
adoption.
So that's really cool.
So in case you haven't kind have
gotten the quick Google+
Sign-In overview, let me just
do that in about 30 seconds
Google+ Sign-In is an
authentication option for
websites, for applications.
And what it's allowing you
to do is use your Google
credentials to log
into websites.
And it makes it much easier than
to have an application
personalized.
And this is sort of a trend
that's happening all
throughout application now,
which is that you expect to
have personalized or familiar
experiences within
applications.
And now Google is making
that very easy.
And we also think that users
prefer Google in that
environment.
They trust Google.
And it's a great choice
to put in front of
users to enable that.
And what we're doing with
Google+ Sign-In is that we are
giving developers this choice
for authentication, but then
we're also putting lots of
functionality underneath it
that's additional value.
So for example, and you might
have seen this example a
couple of times.
When you log in with Google
and if you own an Android
device, we will then open up a
window that says, would you
like to also download
the application?
And so it turns out that 40% of
Android users that log in
with Google then download
the app.
So that's a big number.
And so that's just an
example of the kind
of thing we're doing.
We announced yesterday that once
a user downloads the app,
they're then automatically
logged in.
So what Google will continue to
do over the course of the
next several quarters is release
more and more cool
things for developers, for
businesses, that can help them
build a Google+ integration that
adds significant value.
All right.
So we have three panelists
here today.
We have Jessica Yi from
Fandango, who is the chief
product officer there.
We have Manolo Espinosa, who
is the head of audio at
SoundCloud.
And we also have Robyn
Peterson, who
is the CTO of Mashable.
So these guys have volunteered
to kind of participate today
and share what they're doing.
And what they represent are
just three of the many
companies who said, well, this
product launched at the end of
February, but we want
to be early.
We want to be one of
the case studies.
And so they're going to now
walk you through their
integrations.
So we will begin
with Fandango.
JESSICA YI: Hi everyone.
I'm Jessica.
As many of you probably
know, Fandango is a
movie ticketing company.
We also have a lot of movie
information, a broader
community around it, and you
probably all have used
Fandango for showtimes.
We like to believe that
moviegoing is
largely a social event.
Maybe every now and then
you go by yourself.
But for the most part, you're
doing it with other people.
And there's a broader life cycle
around moviegoing where
you're in three distinct
phases.
Discovery and consideration,
where you're watching
trailers, maybe checking out
reviews, looking at photos,
just learning about movies.
And then once you've decided
you're actually going, you're
in a planning and buying mode.
And then afterwards, you're
in a discussion mode.
And all these phases have
social touchpoints where
you're communicating with either
your immediate friends
or a larger moviegoing
community at large.
So one of the things that
we've focused on in our
implementation that we're
showing here is the middle
phase, where--
that's kind of our sweet spot
of planning and going.
You can see we've revamped our
sign-in page here to make it
really easy, have multiple
options for sign-in.
If you want to carry your
identity with you from Google
or if you already have a
Fandango login, we can tie the
two together.
If you go to the next slide.
You can see, this is a typical
showtimes page.
And at that moment where you've
selected the movie and
the theater and you're
actually looking at a
showtime, we make it really easy
with this integration to
be able to push that out to
your circles or immediate
friends through clicking on
the Google+ icon there.
And then that comes
up as a "join me"
message on a Google platform.
So you don't need to
be on Fandango.
You don't need to
send an email.
You're alerting them across
multiple platforms.
So we think that's going to
have great reach for our
community and be able to join
people in a way they haven't
really done before.
That's one instance of it.
We plan to roll out across
all the multiple
touchpoints pre and post.
So this was a great
start to it.
It's an interactive post.
And I think that another flavor
that we're talking
about-- there's no visual here--
is the app activities.
Trailer watching is actually a
huge activity that is a great
marker for movie interest.
When it first releases, up
through opening weekend, and
even after.
And that kind of aggregated
activity, stuff that doesn't
necessarily show up in a feed,
is really important data.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: Awesome.
Well Jessica, one thing I
think that I was really
interested in, participating
in the process with you and
your team, was how the decision
was made internally
to move forward with
this integration.
What are the consideration
points?
What are the kinds of things
that a company like Fandango
with a structured development
and process--
how do you approach a
development and technology
decision like this?
JESSICA YI: Well there
are two parts.
Obviously, business value and
implementation effort.
On the business value side, we
have over 40 million uniques a
month across our platforms.
And all the interactions that
we have with our customers
sometimes can happen on kind
of a one-off basis.
And what this allows us to do
is really amplify the value
that we're providing to our
customer base and get that
message across multiple
platforms.
So as we're watching trailers,
ratings and reviews, ticket
purchases, any of those
activities can really be
broadcast more widely.
From an implementation
perspective, it didn't take
our team that long
to build it.
So the immediate return was
there for us in that
calculation.
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
All right, we'll now hear from
Manolo talking about
SoundCloud.
MANOLO ESPINOSA: Great.
Thanks, Danny.
First off, I wanted to thank
the Google+ team.
Seth, Danny, Giro, Ardon--
they're an amazingly dedicated
team that's just passionate
about creating a wonderful
service and they've been great
partners to work with.
SoundCloud is the world's
largest audio platform.
We reach about 200 million
users a month.
That's about 8% of
the internet.
Creators upload about 10 hours
of content every minute.
And those creators range from
professional musicians like
Beyonce to folks who
create music out of
their bedroom or basement.
Programs like "This American
Life," the White House,
expectant parents who want to
record the heartbeat of their
child and share that.
We have offices here.
I'm based here in
San Francisco.
But we have offices in Berlin,
London, Sofia, and New York.
And that allows us to leverage
our API, that's really, really
flexible, to provide
an extremely
socially connected service.
One of the things that we're
always looking at-- and I lead
a platform here in
San Francisco--
is how to leverage external
relationships.
So I work with Facebook,
Twitter,
Tumblr, and now Google.
We are extremely passionate
about all
things music and audio.
And so Google+ allowed us to
extend the social experience
and to leverage a
simple sign-on.
We launched Google+ Sign
In on our web app.
Our mobile web.
And just on Monday, our
iOS and Android.
It was a simple process.
Well-documented, great
communication, and we're
excited to continue
iterating on that.
So you see on that first slide,
and on that one right
there as well, that
accessibility early on from an
onboarding perspective,
we think that's great.
What we also did, if you want
to go to the next slide--
this is a basic navigation when
people enter our name,
SoundCloud, in Google search.
One of the things that we think
is really interesting is
that when people are looking for
SoundCloud starting from
Google, they're looking
for content.
And what we want to do is we
want to have a hook to that
content that they're aware of
and can click and get a deep
link to that.
And suddenly be surprised by
content that may be really
popular on SoundCloud and
immediately get to that.
And Google+, with this
integration, if you see on the
next slide, provides us
with a very good hook.
Every day folks start their
navigation from Google.
I'd love it to start on
SoundCloud, but they start
everywhere else as well.
And if they're looking for
something to be able to
provide them a link
right there--
and if you see on the right
side, underneath our logo,
there's a link to an "Economist"
article.
"Economist" has been working
with us for about two years.
They have Economist Radio,
great content.
And clicking on that drives
you right into SoundCloud.
So you can immediately
interact with it.
Listen to it, share it.
And how we get to that content
on Google is because Google+
users are playing and sharing.
And that activity gets moved
over to Google and helps
populate that.
So we think being at the port of
entry, having a presence at
the port of entry there that
provides that deep link is
phenomenal.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: It's a big deal
for Google, because we're
now able to work with a
SoundCloud or Fandango and
actually get activity
information that we can bring
in to places like Search.
So this is an exciting new
data opportunity for us.
And in the process, we're able
to add more links in Search.
And so this is just
the beginning.
But it's neat to have a showcase
like SoundCloud.
All right, Robyn.
ROBYN PETERSON: Great.
Hey everybody.
Robyn Peterson, CTO
of Mashable.
And if you don't know what
Mashable is, basically, in a
nutshell, we're an extremely
social news site.
So what that means is, we cover
the news that's trending
on social sites, like Twitter,
Facebook, Google+.
But we also cover the news--
and this is almost more
important--
the news and cultural nuggets
that are going to trend.
So going about a--
I'm going to give a little
bit of history here.
But going back about a year, we
completely rebuilt Mashable.
It's a custom Ruby
on Rails app.
But down at its core, most
importantly, is something we
call the Velocity algorithm.
And what the Velocity algorithm
really is is a set
of crawlers that go out to
places like Google+ and
Twitter and Facebook and bring
back all this great engagement
data around published
articles.
We then dump that into a
predictive engine that we
created in-house.
And it tells us, quite simply,
what's going to go viral in
about four hours.
So we use that information to
do all sorts of cool things.
We have great dashboards for our
editorial team so they can
stay ahead of what's going
viral on social.
But they also use that
to do cool things
like lay out our homepage.
Our entire homepage and all of
our channel pages are all laid
out by our Velocity algorithm,
deciding which things are
going to go viral and promoting
those in bigger slots.
So the reason I bring that up
this is for two reasons.
If you want to go on to
the next slide, Danny.
So one, since we're so social,
and since we're really almost
becoming one with these social
networks that we cover, any
kind of barriers between where
the story starts--
which is on our site, where the
content is created and the
conversation begins--
to the place where the
conversation then propagates
and, in fact, multiplies.
And a place like Google+
is that exact place.
So what we did here is we not
only integrated login and sign
in and registration--
it's very dramatic with
the music, isn't it?
DANNY BERNSTEIN: There's
something going on in the
other room that's incredible.
ROBYN PETERSON: Yeah.
You dim the lights and.
I'll take you guys on a tour.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: You move
like a live orchestra.
[INAUDIBLE] playoff there,
it's amazing.
ROBYN PETERSON: Yeah.
Exactly.
I kinda liked that.
We could get it back, maybe.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: Yeah,
it's nice.
ROBYN PETERSON: So when you're
on Mashable and you're looking
at an article, you can
share that article,
obviously, to Google+.
When you do that, we're
going to do something
a little bit special.
We're actually going to push
along some information to
Google+ such that, when someone
who's following you on
Google+ sees the article that
you just shared from Mashable,
when they come back, your
profile photo will be on the
Mashable article.
And you will get credit, so to
speak, visual credit for being
the curator of that piece.
And we're doing this for
a couple of reasons.
But really, the main one--
well, there's actually two.
So the top one there is that, in
news, there is a huge theme
in the user-generated space
called "curation."
The curator of a story is almost
as important as the
writer, the creator
of that story.
Because the curator is the one
that picks that story up and
pushes it across the web,
creating this whole viral
snowball effect.
So what we want to do is really
incentivize our readers
to become curators.
And we're doing that here
by putting their
profile photo up there.
And as that link it shared
around on Google+ or on other
places, that curator
gets credit for it.
Which is pretty neat.
And you can see it here, next
to the primary image of this
particular article, at Mashable
we identify these
things called microcontent
within every article.
And those are the elements of
the article that are really
the most shareable.
So in this case,
it's an image.
If someone shares that image,
the person who clicks and
comes back will actually see
the sharer's profile photo
right there and say this person
has shared it with you.
And then here's an example of
what we call in the industry a
pull quote.
But a quote on the article.
This happens to be identified
by the writer of the article
as being a very shareable
element.
And when this particular user
shared it off, and now we're
coming back and looking at it,
we can see that this person is
identified as actually
sharing the article
but from this quote.
So this was the most shareable
element to that person in the
whole article.
Which is kind of neat.
It really kind of incentivizes
that person to keep sharing.
And then the other thing that
we did, going beyond these
slides, is now knowing what you
know about us that we know
everything was built on this
Velocity algorithm and that we
have this really cool display,
we actually just launched a
couple of days ago a
Google Glass app.
If anybody has Google Glass in
the room, it'd be great if you
could connect to it.
What we do there is when our
Velocity algorithm detects
something about to go viral, we
will send an alert to the
people who are wearing Glass who
have connected to our app
and tell them, hey this story
is about to go viral.
And you can either read
that article aloud--
so have Google Glass
read it aloud.
The whole article in your ear,
so you could stay up to date.
And then you can also share
directly from Google Glass and
it will show up just
like this.
So we're integrating it not only
on the site, but also in
Google Glass.
And represented like this.
Really giving credit
to the curator.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: I think one
thing that I noticed and the
team noticed as we were
reviewing the Mashable
integration is that there is a
simple elegance to the way
that the sharing attribution
is displayed.
Which is a striking change
from some of the original
social platform integrations,
where you would
get a capture screen.
You would have an aggressive
sign-up.
So I want to hear a little
bit for you on that.
Because it's as if you are
perhaps leaving some kind of
user registration on the table,
but emphasizing, then,
the user experience and
things like that.
ROBYN PETERSON: Well, at
Mashable, we have 25 million
monthly visitors.
And the ones that follow us on
social networks tend to have
anywhere from three to five
times the average number of
followers on those social
networks compared to the
average person.
So what we're talking about
here is these really
high-clout with a "C"
social networkers.
People who've who really have
big followings on the web.
So in a sense, they're
power users.
They're really power users
of the social web.
So we feel that we really need
to be subtle when we integrate
these kind of elements.
But also do it in a way that
actually rewards that curator.
And that's what we really
aim for here.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: Cool.
Awesome.
Good stuff.
Well, we're now going to move
into a little bit of a
discussion.
And then we will have some time
for questions at the end.
So just to let you guys know.
So one thing that I think is
really important for us is the
Google+ platform represents an
entirely new way that third
parties are working
with Google.
And that's a big deal.
We've had APIs like Maps that
are several years old.
Of course we've had
a Search product.
an Ads product.
But the Google+ platform
is very new.
And I think one thing I'd like
to hear from you guys, and
perhaps to get some thoughts
from the audience as well is,
how can Google become easier
for you to work with?
How can we be easier as
a potential partner?
As a potential platform?
As a potential developer
experience
and things like that.
I'd love to have you
guys opine on that.
Jessica?
JESSICA YI: I'll go first.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: All right.
JESSICA YI: Well, you said,
"easier." But I think being
effective is something that
we're thinking about.
We've talked about the life
cycle of the customer and the
different touchpoints that a
user could have with Fandango
in the various phases.
And how Fandango experiences
represented across the Google
platforms could manifest
differently.
So one of the things I think
is really important is to
think holistically about how
Fandango and Google appear to
the customer in the different
life cycles.
So perhaps on an opening
weekend, which is kind of the
height of our value, when
you're doing a search on
Google, you're seeing
what's hot, what's
selling this weekend.
Earlier on in a different
context for a different
keyword or something,
we could be
servicing content for discovery.
And again, back to the other
touch points, like how does it
appear on Gmail?
Or how does it appear in Search
and other platforms?
So it would be great to paint
a holistic picture for the
user and say, what's the best
way we could work together to
create that kind of collective
experience as opposed to
looking at it from a
product standpoint.
And then seeing how you can
apply it back to the business.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: That's
interesting.
When we often talk to companies,
they tell us that
things like user registration,
like sharing, like identity,
are really, really hard.
And they're looking to
Google to help solve
some of those things.
But in reality, those
things have been
really hard for Google.
And part of what Google+ is, as
we think about how we work
with partners, is that it is
a common sense of identity
across all of Google.
It's a common way to share
It's a common notification
system across all of Google.
And it's a common system
of friends.
And two years ago, those
things did not exist.
So we have products like
the little red
notification square.
And so the fact we're now able
to unify these products, and
that there's a common set of
rules and systems and APIs,
that makes things a heck
of a lot easier.
So that's sort of how we've
thought about it.
ROBYN PETERSON: And I would say
on our side, just building
on what you're talking about
there, Danny, this notion of
multifaceted identity, I think,
really needs to be
understood by Google.
And that's quite simply--
just taking me as the example.
So I have my personal account.
And that's what I've
set up Google+ on.
And that's where I'm posting
all my kid photos and all
those things like that.
And then at Mashable, we're
Google Apps customers, so I
have my @mashable.com
version of me.
And that's my business me and
my personal me, and I keep
having to flip accounts
constantly.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: And I know
you also have your
breakdancing account as well.
ROBYN PETERSON: Yeah.
Well, that's all
animated .gifs.
So that's a little easier.
But if there was this understood
notion that I'm
more than just one email
account, so to speak--
there's a personal side to me,
there's a business side of me.
And how does Google understand
that both of those exist?
DANNY BERNSTEIN: I think we've
heard quite a bit of that this
week in a lot of different
sessions.
Is how to reconcile those, and
also what is the data that
you're missed that's missing
and things like that.
So we've heard that one
loud and clear this
week, quite a few times.
It's good.
MANOLO ESPINOSA: So my thoughts
are less on the
technology side but more
on partnerships.
We work with, for example, a lot
of content creators that
are journalists.
And they want to work with us
because we can help get their
content across other social
networks in a
really, really easy way.
And they, like a lot of people,
see Google as an
amazingly large company with so
many different touchpoints.
And they look to us to help
connect them to that.
I think a good example is how
we can work with this
integration and how that ties
into Google News, for example.
And this is a relationship.
You start working
on something.
You iterate.
You get better over time.
You see other opportunities.
And any of those opportunities
that we can then pass along to
our creators is a huge
opportunity, therefore, for us
to make something very big and
change the way people discover
and share that content.
It is an interesting thing when
you are looking at taking
something that's so socially
connected and connect it
across a company as
large as Google.
And I think anything that the
organization can do to help
clear that up is very useful.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: Great.
Awesome.
So one last question, and then
I think we'll open it up to
the audience, is when you're
approaching decisions like
this, how are you--
and we heard from Jessica
on this point earlier.
But how are you arousing
consensus and approaching
something like this?
And you guys, at this point,
are anywhere from 50 to
several hundred people inside
of your companies.
And then are taking adding
a new sign-in option.
That's significant.
How did you think about that?
How are you are you thinking
about the process before?
And then also how are you
thinking about it in terms of
assessing value?
ROBYN PETERSON: I think
this one was kind of a
no-brainer for us.
We already had Google+ Sign-In,
the previous version.
And we have a very strong
Google audience.
Over 2 million likes,
I believe, on
Google+ on our main page.
But then if you add up all
of our writers' personal
followings, and those sorts
of things, it's
some n times that.
Some x times that.
So we have a really
big following.
And we know that the people who
are really going to enjoy
this feature are going to be
the power users of Google+.
So for us, we derive so much
value from curators on the
web, people sharing our content,
that this is just one
more step we can take to
really accelerate that
MANOLO ESPINOSA: For us, it was
a combination of listening
to our users, who want things to
be super, super simple, but
also listening to our
content partners.
And we had heard loud and clear
that they wanted to be
able to have integration and
embedding and experience there
with Google+.
Listening to those two parties,
and then, clearly,
working within an organization,
our priorities,
our road map, it's packed
all the time.
We are always struggling
with that.
This one was, I think, the
combination of just prudent
risk-taking, honestly.
Looking at, does this make sense
for us, and having a
leap of faith, and saying,
look, I think--
DANNY BERNSTEIN: And in this
case, working across a couple
different time zones as well.
MANOLO ESPINOSA: Time zones.
Multiple offices.
We decided to do it across
all our web app,
mobile apps, et cetera.
Just a lot of the things that
had to synchronize.
And ultimately, we thought that
by listening to what our
users wanted and our content
partners wanted,
that was good thing.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: All right.
Well, we definitely have some
time for questions.
So anybody in the audience want
to ask questions for our
panelists here?
Nobody?
Oh.
We've got somebody here.
I think you're first.
AUDIENCE: First!
All the screen shots that you
shared, there was a big red
button alongside a
big blue button.
How does, specifically, Google+
compare to other
networks or social
media platforms?
Does it bring more value to you,
or how does it compare?
[INAUDIBLE].
ROBYN PETERSON: Yeah, sure.
You know, we do see
differences between the networks.
But to be honest, there's
a few different
users that we see.
There's users who are just
hardcore Google+ users,
hardcore Twitter users hardcore
Facebook users.
But I think those users
are actually
somewhat rare in our world.
I think we see more poly-network
users, so to
speak, where they're using a
bunch of different networks.
And they use them for
different things.
So for instance, to throw one
out that we didn't talk about
here, how about LinkedIn.
So LinkedIn performs very well
for Mashable when we're
talking about trends in the job
market, or something about
how to use some certain aspect
of social in your career.
It's not it's not uncommon for
those particular stories to be
at the top of the charts
for LinkedIn.
Google tends to do well.
The Google users tend to
really enjoy Google I/O
content, for one.
That's doing-- yeah, who
would have known?
That's doing quite
well for us.
But there's just different
personas with each network.
And we see them ebb and flow
based upon that content.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: We have
heard from a couple of
partners this week.
So many of these integrations
are just brand new.
And this product actually
only launched
at the end of February.
But three notable stats I heard
this week from partners
that are now OK to share.
One is that "The Guardian," the
UK newspaper, shared that
on their Android app, that
Google+ is now the preferred
option of users.
It's 41 percent of their social
login, and that's the
biggest number.
And I heard from both Flixster
and SkillPages that,
basically, their social logins
are evenly divided now between
Google+ and Facebook.
It's really interesting,
especially because Facebook's
option launched four years ago
and we've been in the market
for now less than
three months.
So we think we think having
user choice is a really,
really good idea.
And there actually are
very different use
cases for both of those.
So generally speaking, we
think choice is good.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Check.
Hey, guys.
I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about the
content personalization for us
publishers in the audience.
Like for Fandango, and
SoundCloud, and Mashable, we
saw some of the things-- like
with Mashable, how you said
the user really liked this
piece of the article.
Are we going to see more
homepage landings personalized
based on a social sign-in?
ROBYN PETERSON: Yeah.
It's a great question.
I think that's going to be a big
part of what you see for
Mashable coming over
the next year.
If you think about what we've
done so far, we're just
watching, in a sense,
macro-trends of what's
happening with content.
So this kind of article
is about to go viral.
And that one is too.
But really, the more interesting
nugget is, within
your group of friends, maybe
this one's going viral but
your friends haven't
seen it yet.
That would be fantastic
for us.
And these are the kinds of
things that we're going to try
to tackle at Mashable.
And I think that goes
right to the sweet
spot of your question.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: All right.
One question for you, Robyn,
related to that is Mashable
adopting these things early.
Are you engaging with other
media companies now who are
kind of saying to you, well,
you're using this with social
login, hey, how do we do this?
Can you productize it?
That kind of stuff?
ROBYN PETERSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
We actually have heard
that a lot.
We've heard that a lot about
Velocity in particular, can we
productize that.
It's something that we're
thinking about.
It's something you could
see from us over the
next year or two.
We're not sure.
But we actually spend a lot of
time working with other media
companies just trying to get
out of our competitive mind
spaces and work together to
advance media in general.
Because it's a tough landscape
right now, right?
68% of ad dollars for display
ads goes to 5 companies that
are historically thought of
as the top tech companies.
Which means that this pie
that's left for media
companies to go after is getting
smaller and smaller.
So all us media companies need
to work together and start
thinking more like
tech companies.
And that's really how
we're going to
get ahead and survive.
JESSICA YI: I have one thing
to add to that on
the Fandango side.
For content recommendations and
movie recommendations, you
could have a Netflix-like
algorithm for that based on
past purchase history.
But a lot of it's based on my
circle of friends might have
similar tastes to me, and that
we could make recommendations
based on your friends who've
watched certain trailers or
purchased tickets, or certain
genre interests.
And then we can additionally
curate content for upcoming
movies and movie news and
casting information.
Things like that, based on
your interest levels.
MANOLO ESPINOSA: And for
us, it's really new.
We're just pushing on this.
We have been working on
recommendation stuff.
But that's the power of
innovating, right?
You lean forward.
You try something.
You iterate.
If it's something you really
care passionately about, come
work with us.
We're hiring.
That's something that we're
always interested in, getting
other people's perspectives.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: Content
recommendations, I think, is
one of the hardest things
for publishers to build.
And so we've spoken now to
dozens of publishers.
And they all have a very stated
desire to innovate
around content recommendations
and
personalization of content.
That being said, those tech
resources always seem to get
diverted to building video
ads and things like that.
So that's really, really
challenging.
That being said, we launched
a content-recommendations
product for mobile websites
just a couple of days ago.
It's live on "Forbes."
So that's an area we're also
really excited about.
And you'll see a steady wave of
innovation around that from
Google, because we really
want to democratize that
capability.
Because it is so hard.
It's so hard to do.
It's so difficult
to integrate.
It really is.
It's reserved for the heavily,
heavily-resourced few.
And we want to try
to change that.
MANOLO ESPINOSA: And I think it
also goes to point that you
don't, therefore, want to spend
those resources doing
things like complicated
sign-ins.
You want to do an
easy sign-in.
You don't want to have to
worry about how to force
people to do installs.
You doing an over-the-air
install with Android.
You go for the simple things
that are all tied together in
one package.
Then you can deploy those
resources on things that are
really, really tough.
DANNY BERNSTEIN: All right.
Any other questions?
All right.
Well, thank you guys so much
for doing this and for
participating here, for being
in our Sandbox, and for
integrating so early.
We really appreciate it.
So thank you.
JESSICA YI: Thank you.
ROBYN PETERSON: Thank you.